um hello everybody today we're going to
be looking at a very particular uh
opening but what I want to get across is
more how the process through which I
came to like this opening so the opening
today as you may be able to see from the
title is the Queen's Gambit accepted and
so uh one of the so uh this is not an
opening that is super highly contested
at the highest level of Chess or
anything like that although it is
starting to become a bit more popular
there but what's really nice about it is
that it's very easy to learn and for the
most part you have the option between
either simplifying the game very fast if
that's your cup of tea
um
and very nice to do with black pieces a
lot of the time or entering some
convocations with at White's discretion
so without further Ado let's jump into
some Theory
so what we have at the beginning here so
uh the the game in particular is not so
important for the base game I've
selected a game of my friend who's using
my preparation
but this is not particularly important
where we're trying to get across here is
the theory more than the game
so we see D4 so basically this was
played in a norm tournament in Charlotte
where my friend International Master
Edward song is playing black and the
Canadian I am Raja panjwani is playing
white so D4 D5 C4 and take C4
so uh of course there are various side
lines but the general idea for white is
to is that there are a couple of main
serious options so one of them is the
setup with E3 and Knight F3 uh for the
repertoire that I am suggesting the
order does not matter
um
as for the most part white is going to
continue in the same way regardless and
the other one is E4 which we're going to
look at in just a little bit here but I
want to start off by talking about
Knight F3 Knight F6 E3 E6 so this
position also occurs uh activation Pig
C4 so this position also very frequently
occurs from 3e3 and you have pretty much
exactly the same position in this case
and so then I think that this is a
really useful tool because it makes it
so that you don't have to learn anything
different against these lines some
people play a setup with Knight F6 and
Bishop G4 here and some people play E5
in this position but I think that it's
much simpler to just play the same thing
since it's very good
so after E6 Bishop takes C4 so at first
if you're not familiar with the opening
it looks a lot like
um like we've simply just given up our
Center and developed White's pieces for
free but the truth is that white has
some issues with the D4 Pawn so A6 is
pretty much an essential move for black
and for this we're going to be using
this game to primarily talk about these
setups that include the move A4 although
I briefly meant so in the game white
actually did play A4 on this move
although it's significantly more common
for white to Castle first and then after
C5 play A4
in this position actually I should also
mention that it's it's quite popular for
white to take on C5 as well
but I don't really understand why I
never really thought that this end game
was particularly dangerous
um so I mean just to just to make
matters a little bit more clear I mean
people often play Knight B2 and Bishop
E2 surprisingly common and if we follow
this game between
Wesley so playing white and Abdul Satora
playing Black this is just from the
recent wike Anze tournament Jesus that
was loud
um
we had this just from the recent walking
day tournament Wesley so was able to
show a very quick Equalization so Knight
B3 is not optimal because the Knight is
a little bit strangely placed on B3 and
indeed in this position black is
generally fairly comfortable in this end
game
uh but after B3 Bishop B5 white ends up
with a little bit of trouble trying to
convert an advantage here and indeed
Wesley so managed to draw fairly
smoothly I'm not even sure whether the
loss of the C4 Bishop is necessary
um but yeah there's not really too much
to talk about in this game it's just
trading pieces and then eventually a
draw
um too bright for you why was A6
essential so uh yes let's go let's go
back to that for a second so in this
position
um A6 to say that A6 is essential is
sort of a lie because you don't actually
have to play A6 in this position you can
start with C5 as well
um but so so Asics a very useful move
because uh so let's say this position
the committing of the Knight to C6 very
early allows white to play D5 in many
lines like for example white can play
Knight C3 and rush for a very quick D5
which could be annoying a lot of lines
um and so A6 is a little bit more
flexible and by introducing the option
of B5 to quickly develop the bishop on
B7 threatens a queen side expansion that
very frequently baits white into playing
A4 which we're going to talk about today
um and there's there's another game
where we're going to look at what
happens when white allows B5 which is
extremely common these days as well so
uh does that answer your question too
bright for you
geez
um okay so anyway so we have A6 in the
game and after A4 we're looking at C5 so
the key here is that the move A6 incites
A4 a4s is generally regarded as sort of
like an older line
um since nowadays white finds this a
little bit annoying so the key here is
that you're almost certainly going to
end up in an isolated Queen pawn pawn
structure so white can still play by
taking on C5 but with the pawn and A4
white is definitely not going to have an
advantage in the end game as any sort of
Queen side expansion is not going to be
uh very effective so after C5 you're
most likely going to end up in a pawn
structure with an isolated Queen con for
white
and uh and and that can be very uh
annoying for for White 2 to play with
um mainly because in an iqp structure
one of the main Maneuvers for black is
to play Knight B4 it's D5 and so if you
look at other openings where the iqp
appears like the C3 Sicilian or the
nimso Indian perhaps white usually will
play A3 in order to prevent this from
happening but of course that is not
possible enough to pause on A4 and this
whole on V4 will be very problematic so
we're about to see how that pans out in
the game so Castle is Knight C6 probably
putting pressure on D4 and threatening
to take on D4
um
so in this position white has two major
branches of play although they mostly
end up in the same position so due to
The Peculiar characteristics of this
position white pretty much has to set up
the pieces with Queen E2 and Rook D1
just because the e-file is not yet open
so The Rook will not be effective on E1
and since this trade has cleverly been
held off on by black the dark Square
Bishop is not effective so white can
either start by playing Queen E2
immediately or with Knight C3 first
I believe Queen E2 immediately is more
accurate and that is what Azure played
in the game after Knight C3
so this is what so this is a a really
great example of the utility of the
Queen's gamut accepted and that you
basically don't really have to know any
you don't really have to know very much
in order to make a very smooth draw
against one of the most common lines
here so I have Knight C3 Bishop E7 Queen
E2 because the e-file is closed black is
now able to actually grab the pawn on D4
of course taking on D4 allows black to
assembly capture and this position uh
it's a little bit complicated because
the queen on D4 is is not optimal but at
the same time black is up a pawn and
should have a small advantage
just click
okay Rook D1 so after C takes D4 a white
would usually play Rook D1 and now
because the E5 is closed black is able
to play E5 and hold on to this Pawn
if white wishes to regain it white would
have to play at Knight takes D4 and
queen E5 but after Queen D6 uh position
is incredibly safe for black and after
it takes takes Rook takes D4 both Bishop
E5 and Bishop C5 are completely fine uh
I believe Bishop E5 is the subject of a
of a recent game in China between uh and
uh Li Chao and so and Bishop E5 the idea
of playing Bishop E6 and taking on C3 to
trade a bunch of pieces I think Bishop
C5 is perhaps even simpler Rook D1
Bishop E6 and this sort of end game is
becoming uh pretty widely contested not
this uh exact position uh really this is
not a super common exact position but
the isolated E Pawn generally does not
prove to be super dangerous for black in
the end game since it's very difficult
for white to uh
to attack and King on F7 Rick the gate
should result in a very safe end game
for black
Donald asks if we can go over that again
yes exactly so very good it's always
good to review
so after Knight C6 so in the game that
we're looking at today white played
Queen 2 first which is the most common
and I believe the best move but after
Knight C3 so we're looking at Bishop E7
and uh so in this position white is
actually fairly short of useful moves uh
is a big problem uh White can play D5
but in this case it's not so impressive
for various reasons mostly because the
A4 Pawn being here makes this b4a5
complex very weak
and the most common move Queen 2 allows
CD4 and Rook D1 E5 holding on to this
Pawn because the e-file has now been
sealed by that Bishop
so as I outlined before if white wishes
to regain the pawn this sequence is
forced after which Queen D6 allows black
to transition to a very very safe end
game
the other the the thing that I like
about Bishop C5 in this position is that
if white takes on
uh
so if white takes on D4 with the queen
here you can simply transition to the
same position if you so desire
uh wait why not take Knights uh what do
you mean Donald
what you just explained that was it
uh
what do you mean so
yeah uh so like
because the bishop is on E7 and take
Knight and what what do you mean take
the yeah if I so Queen E5 Queen D6 and
um whenever white takes the Knight you
will simply just transition into this
end game with Bishop E6
um oh okay yes yeah all right so
anyway so that's very nice because this
is one of the major branches for white
and we've already pretty much knocked it
out as a try for Advantage
um so that's so that's pretty amazing
already I mean it's very rare that in
the opening you can already say that
whites what a White's main moves is
completely useless so
after Queen E2
um now C takes D4 Rook D1 so in this
case E5 is no longer feasible because
the bishop is not blocking the king here
so after e takes D4 we would probably
just lose the game and that's not very
good so we want to play Cartoon
development Bishop E7 now if white
wishes to avoid the iqp pawn structure
it so happens that uh that black is very
well equipped to meet this noticeably
the white pieces don't really have any
development to speak of so black is very
safe here so if white wishes to play for
a manager must be e takes D4 castles and
Knight C3 and here we can see that white
would really love to take back the move
A4 if it were possible since in this
case white is threatening to play D5 and
indeed if white were able to play D5 the
position would come open slight Square
Bishop would become super powerful and
black might be in some trouble
but black is an excellent way to stop D5
here with move Knight B4
so after night before so white has a
couple of moves but the long story short
is that with the iqp you always want to
with both sides make sure you have
control of the square in front of it as
much as possible so as to blockade it
and prevent it from being traded off
and in this case it is very clear that
it is white who has lost that battle so
95 is uh the best move in order to try
to gain some space and take advantage of
the knights departure from C6 and black
has a couple of ways to play uh the move
Bishop D7 was actually played in a
recent game between dubov and Daniel
dubov and Wesley so
um and this is totally fine with the
idea of transitioning the bishop to C6
and recapture on C6 with the b-pawn to
further control D5 S9 on B4 will end up
becoming an absolute monster in that
position so it will make up for the loss
of the bishop pair
and that's totally fine but for me B6 is
the most natural move and that is what
Edward played in this game
so uh after B6 uh yeah this just feels
more natural to me just trying to place
the bishop on a long diagonal and
keeping it open I'm not overly worried
about the loss of control over C6 just
because the Knight on B4 cannot actually
be removed by really any means so uh in
the game panjwani decides to try to
punish the freshly opened long diagonal
with Queen F3 uk7 and queen H3 so why
does transition the queen over to H3 and
might be looking for some attacking
Chances with Bishop G5 in the future but
here we can already see another key
component of why Black's position is so
safe here the bishop on C4 is not able
to re reroute to hit the H7 Pawn on
account of the squares all being
controlled by our monstrous night on the
board
so overall very nice position for black
and indeed after Rook C7 Bishop B3 uh
black is clearly the more active person
here and is even able to take matters
into his own hands with Knight fd5
so in the game after Bishop D2 and the
game black was able to make an uh
excellent move here with uh the idea of
trading minor pieces remember that with
the iqp they side with iqp generally
does not wish to trade minor pieces as
this would result in a loss of activity
and Rooks are generally pretty effective
against the iqp excellent move here
Bishop G5 played in order to eliminate
this bishop and weaken White's control
of C3
so after Queen G3 takes takes and Bishop
B7
um
after Bishop B7 uh yeah black is
incredibly safe here notably the light
Square Bishop is very difficult to
reroute to a more active post and black
if anything has the superior minor
pieces here as well as the better Pawn
structure
uh thank you Tetris crab that's very
sweet
um okay Rook dd1 Queen E7
and A5 to try to break open the queen
Side Pawn structure it's very difficult
to think of another plan for white
um
so white is trying to make the C5 Square
available so if black wish to um
preserve the pawn structure on the queen
side with B5 then 94 would allow a
knight to jump right into C5
so quad takes A5 94 and Knight F6
so in this position Knight C5 black can
do virtually anything but Bishop D5
appears very attractive just eliminating
those light Square Bishops and keeping a
knight on D5 forever
so Knight takes F6 happened in the game
and white wins back the a pawn but the
position remains very difficult for
white to play
now after Bishop takes D5 Knight takes
D5
I believe there was something wrong if
it takes A6
Rook takes A6 I think Knight F4 and
there's some problems for white here
um
yeah something like that uh I mean the
the remaining moves in the game are not
really that important I believe White
Lake screws up at one point and it
becomes possible for black to uh
for black to have a win or something but
it's not a super huge deal
um
yeah the blacklight takes on C5 first
and then plays H6 it's very difficult or
white to save the C5 pawn and black
should win here but at this point both
players are in time trouble and uh the
the general status quo that uh that that
the position is roughly equal should not
really have changed a whole lot although
and it really only does so just because
of some errors in time trouble and
therefore uh not going to cover the move
specifically I mean essentially the
objective of what I've been trying to
get through with this lecture has
already been proven that black is able
to just reach a very safe position very
quickly and this iqp structure with the
move A4 is not overall very dangerous
okay so uh now that we've pretty much
covered the A4 iqp setup as well as a
little bit on dtake C5 now we can move
on to the slightly more modern setup
where white avoids the move A4
so after D4 D5 C4 takes sorry so next
game we're looking at is also a game
where International Master Edward song
is playing Black this time against the
Hungarian Grandmaster Sarah's lahos I
really hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly
so after a C4 do you take C4
Knight F3 Knight F6 so in this game
after Bishop takes C4 white elected not
to play A4
so after A6 we have castles C5 and
Bishop B3 so this is a slightly more
Modern Way for white to step out of the
way of the move B5
and so now B5 does not come with the
tempo and is therefore at severely
weakened for black
of course my advice is that black should
do it anyway and after A4 there's quite
a bit of theory here and
black has tried a bunch of moves in this
position but I believe the best one is
the relatively new but uh very computer
friendly move C4
so I know this move might look a little
bit strange but the key is that the
white Bishop is going to be relegate it
to this sort of sub-optimal square on C2
and the B5 Pawn is therefore going to be
very difficult for white to attack and
after Bishop B7 takes takes takes takes
so in this position uh the most likely
Pawn structure is that white will play
B3 at some point and trade the B Pawn
for the C Pawn so an example of that
would look like C takes B3 and white
would prefer not to take the on B3 with
the bishop as the bishop is not Super
Active on the A2 to G8 diagonal
um so Bishop D3 is more likely but in
this particular case you will find you
will hopefully find in your practical
game set is very difficult for white to
win with this General Pawn structure as
the B4 Pawn is always very annoying in
most end games and I believe that with
best play theoretically you should
eventually see a trade exchange of these
pawns with a fairly smooth draw
and yeah basically just without the
queen side pawns it's going to be very
difficult for a white to do much of
anything here in my opinion
so in the game white played the move
Knight C3
but after B4 we see the problem with the
white Bishop on C2 it is not a
particularly strong piece here
so uh White should probably play 92 but
this is not really too impactful to
Black's original plan simply Knight D7
and getting ready to Castle seems
perfectly appropriate to me
um Knight on E2 is not super optimal
here so
we have uh it's in the game instead
Whiteside to play Bishop A4 check and
after my bd7 played Knight A2 so this is
a slightly more appealing Square just to
keep some more pressure on the B and C
pawns but concretely it does have some
issues here
so after Bishop D6 the idea of white
setup is to play Knight E5 and continue
the pressure on the C4 and B4 pawns but
it's incredibly difficult for white to
actually make use of this as we're about
to see
so Queen C7 very nice move here
protecting C4 and adding an additional
attacker to E5
what do you think about forcing double
Pawn white goes 92
uh oh like here uh yeah sure
um yeah I think that this is probably
not very effective
um so firstly because the um
it's very difficult for black to do
anything to White's King just because
it's exposed here the loss the bishop
will make it a lot harder to connect the
C4 Pawn an account of Bishop not having
Bishop D5 anymore overall I think the
black light screw Bishop is a much more
powerful piece in that Knight on F3 so I
really don't want to make that trade
does that make sense
okay so B4
um yeah so where are we all right back
here Queen C7 adding an additional
attacker protector to Z4 and uh White
continues with Bishop D2 putting
pressure on B4 so
um at first it looks like white has a
pretty challenging initiative here and
that's actually a big reason I want to
go over this game the line that white
played in this game is is not an
impressive line but by any means
um but it is important to know what to
do against it because it is
theoretically critical and what I mean
by that is it's not critical in that
it's a very good line and with best play
we are like worse or anything like that
what I mean by that is just simply that
it's critical because if we don't know
what to do then it's not very good for
us
like for example I would say the king's
Gambit is a critical try in the E4 E5
just because it is challenging to meet
but not because it's objectively good so
that's what I mean by critical in this
context
so after Bishop D2 white continues to
add attackers to the B4 Pawn but it
actually so happens that this is not
particularly relevant so let's see if
any of the viewers here want to take a
stab at black to move in this position
oh
could you go over the king's Gambit uh
this loans lecture does have a slightly
different topic
um
I also don't know anything about
anything really serious about King's
Gambit so I wouldn't really have too
much input there
um so so something like Queen to B8 is
possible the thing is we're actually
precluding ourselves from castling by
playing Queen V8
um
so if white were to Simply protect this
complex with something like F4 so C4 is
under threat now and we're not able to
Castle it's definitely a very dangerous
situation for black overall
so the key here is to understand that
white is not actually really threatening
the B4 Pawn so oh hey chest Pawn how are
you doing Wyoming Matt has the best
suggestion here with short castling
so now if white wishes to collect the
pawn with Knight takes D7 967 and Bishop
takes B4
uh black has a pretty amusing tactic
here with Bishop takes B4 Knight B4 and
queen B7
uh perhaps Queen B7 first is a slightly
better to move order in this particular
case
and after F3 Bishop takes B4
um Knight takes B4 white is able to
avoid the loss of material but after
Queen takes B2 the C3 Pawn is very
powerful and makes it so that black does
not really have any serious troubles in
his position if anything white is
definitely going to be worse here as
after something like Bishop A4 uh just
some sample moves White's definitely the
person who has the harder time with the
advance of the black C Pawn
so in the game white did not go for that
and white instead played F4 but now
after the simple move Rook B8 we can see
uh further uh illustration of my point
with Tetris crab how our Bishop on A8 is
incredibly powerful controls V squares
D5 and E4 the Y is not able to oh my
goodness thank you so much vampire
chicken nice raid 114. thank you well
that's really cool
um
yeah that's huge thank you so much
um so
so yeah we have Rook B8 just protecting
the B4 Pawn Yeah Baby
yeah
thank you for that
um okay yeah so Rook B8 protects B4
um and white is not going to be able to
take back this move F4 uh does a great
job of cementing E5 but does a much
worse job of protecting the E4 and D5
squares and indeed after Queen E2 black
is already uh pretty much winning in
this position
by letting go of the A4 Bishop
um I mean to be honest this position is
already fairly close to to winning for
black
um after Queen E2 Queen A7 the pressure
on A4 and by extension A2 is extremely
problematic
uh so in this position white played B3
which is a very sad move but I'm
guessing that the original intention of
taking on D7 didn't really work out here
for several reasons first of all Queen
takes A4 is very strong oh sorry Queen
takes A2 is very strong but also I think
this is probably in working order 9182
is very loose and so we can see that
this Knight on A2 was placed here to for
activity purposes but concretely it's
just not working out so in the game
white played B3 which is a pretty
hideous move just because C3 is now
fully possible and is protected past
Pawn on C3 is almost certainly going to
win black the game
indeed after Bishop E1 Knight B6
white is forced to exchange pieces on C6
but unfortunately for white any exchange
of minor pieces in this position brings
back closer to what brings black closer
to a winning end game with uh the
extremely powerful Pawn on C3
Knight C1 just trying to reroute the
Knight obviously it's not doing anything
on A2 anymore Queen V6 so uh White
definitely does not want to take on D5
as this Knight on e4 is going to get
cemented on e4 and absolutely dominate
that terrible Whitefish run one
so uh Bishop A4 was played in the game
but after 94 black is just completely
dominating here
is there any way to know when to feel
comfortable to isolate your own Queen on
the queen side that just depends on the
position sorry not really too much I can
offer you there
um
so after Knight D3
trying to bring the Knight into the game
Knight would look very pretty on E5 so
of course uh Edward does a great job of
stopping that with the move Queen six
just completely killing that idea in its
tracks
so after Queen A6 the Knight is not able
to move
so white decides to try to go for some
active operations with F5
and of course black does not wish to
open up the king side says black is
doing so well on this side so simply E5
white is not able to take it to the pin
on the 860 F1 diagonal
Bishop H4 activates the bishop but
unfortunately it allows black to force a
trade of Queens
and black is winning here in a dozen
different ways I mean we can just look
at these two pieces and just see that
white has not really been doing too much
constructive with this time so far
Bishop E7 I thought was a pretty nice
trick here so Bishop takes E7 Knight
takes E7 white will have a lot of
trouble protecting the F5 Pawn in the
end game
and Bishop G3 Rook B6 is similarly
effective the game black simply
collected the F5 Pawn
and white resigned here
it's only it's only one Pawn but more
importantly if we just look at some of
the white minor pieces we can see that
it's pretty much no doubt that black
should be able to win the game
so believe it or not we've actually
pretty much theoretically covered the
major
the one of two major systems for white
this Knight F3 E3 system
um so in that's pretty amazing right I
mean in a 30 minutes lecture I mean what
can you do normally right but we've we
pretty much theoretically covered uh
showing some model games and ideas
um
the pretty much the major system for
white to play of course there are
various Sidelines that people are
playing now and uh I I don't really
intend to uh cover them all today but my
main illustration here is the main
objective of what I've been doing right
here is to discuss How uh
is to discuss how easy this opening is
to Play and Learn so you pretty much
need to understand the iqp pawn
structure and this C5 B5 and then you're
going to be set against the early E3
uh unfortunately or fortunately
depending on who you are
um
the more common setup for white uh
trying to play for advantage against the
Queen's Gambit accepted does not involve
this Knight of three E3 setup so
um after D4 D5 C4 takes but people
mostly play in this position now at the
high level to try to win the game is E4
so E4 is of course more combative than
E3 just taking over the center and the
same time much riskier so the approach
that I advocate today may actually not
be a great secret since it is fairly
topical in uh High ELO chest nowadays
but uh
uh maybe a bit of the flex but I think
my I think I discovered this earlier
than most people
um
so after E4 I play the pound of attack
of the caracon yeah okay so after E4 the
approach I'm recommending is the most
aggressive and combative setup for Black
available or I wouldn't say that but B5
is definitely the critical test of
White's idea in the case of E3 this is
not really feasible since you're not
able to hold on to your Pawn on account
of exposing the long diagonal and losing
material
but after E4 that is not the case so
after E4 B5 A4 C6
takes takes we have a pretty interesting
position where black has an extra con
and white has a great Pawn Center
so in this position if white wishes to
continue with normal moves it's not uh
particularly dangerous for example a B3
is very standard to try to break up this
Pawn structure but due to the
flexibility of Black's position E5 is
already possible and white is not going
to appreciate this end game very much so
um so the most critical tries to play
Knight C3 if white does nothing black
will simply play E6 Bishop E7 and A6 and
V up upon truth is white still has
compensation there and we're actually
about to look at something very similar
to that in just a little bit but of
course it should not be terribly
dangerous and uh for perhaps I have some
personal bias since I used to play the
semi-slave and my intention was to take
on C4 as fast as possible and now I can
and but now I've solved the Cardinal
Problem by taking on C4 a couple moves
earlier
so in the game we so in this game uh
which involves uh slavrula so lucky
dough
playing white I believe she's an IM and
my good friend Dottie Lynn playing Black
after Knight C3
which is the most common move so
traditionally there have been a couple
of ways for black to play I should start
off by saying that uh his super
historically like quite a while ago this
position was regarded as simply very bad
for black as it is very difficult to
hold on to the B5 pawn and some of the
older lines involved bizarre moves like
Bishop D7 which is pretty clearly not
what black wants to be doing since the
bishop definitely belongs in the lying
diagonal here
and so a couple of years back people
started playing this interesting
exchange sacrifice with A6 and a takes
B5
and in this position
um
the idea for black is that the
development is very fast and the
position is positionally very
satisfactory with the bishop in the
proper place
however
recent theory has indicated this is
probably not uh it's probably not the
optimal way for black to handle the
position and it seems like White's
position is just a little bit too safe
for this to be super sound
so uh this move Queen B6 which I am
recommending today
I'm not sure who is the discoverer as I
I looked it up and apparently there are
a couple of older games with this line
but um
but I will attribute it to my good
friend Grandmaster Andrew Hong who was
the first person to uh
to alert me to its existence and indeed
he actually played one of the stem games
in the long one of the lines that we're
going to look at he played the stem game
uh hung against theodoro or Theodore
against Hong of course it's in song is
black so
so what does this move Queen B6 do well
first of all obviously it protects B5
this is not a big secret so effects B5
the queen here does a great job of
protecting B5 putting pressure on D4 and
black is fully prepared to Simply
develop the uh
Bishop here and get the pieces out and
if black is able to do that then black
is going to have a very pleasant
position so in this stem game that we're
looking at today which is Soak you do
against Lin
um
that is indeed what happened white
decided to play Bishop E2 very safe move
and E6 Knight H3 to bring the Knight to
the interesting F4 Square
could the Knight go to D5 yes we're
about to talk about that very soon so uh
so the reason that uh that Queen B6 was
historically not booked upon favorably
is because Knight D5 does put a lot of
pressure on black and we're going to
talk about that very soon so just hold
tight and we're going to get to the
theoretically interesting lines so
Bishop E2 was played in this game and
after E6 not H3 Bishop B4 castles in 97.
the knight's generally better on E7 than
F6 and many of these types of positions
as to not be in the way of any E5
tactics or anything like that so after
97 Bishop E3 black actually does not
need to be super worried about the
existence of any discoveries with D5 as
Bishop C5 will always serve as a pretty
natural counter to that
so castles Bishop F3 Bishop B7 and so
white is not terribly worse in this
position white as I mentioned before
white actually does have pretty powerful
compensation just in the form of uh the
really strong Center and white doesn't
really have any bad pieces so white is
not terribly worse but we can see that
the position is pretty easy to play for
black I mean it just seems like black
has developed all the pieces with very
natural moves and after Queen E2 97
um
black already has a pretty harmonious
setup again white doesn't need to be
super afraid of anything but it for me I
will always prefer to play Black in this
type of position just because at the end
of the day I do have an extra Pawn
so we have Rook D1 and Knight f8 so nine
of eight is a pretty nice move just
reopening this file and preemptively
protecting E6 in the case of some D5
tactics
so in this position it's already very
difficult to to suggest a plan for white
if I was more invested in the details of
this specific game I might go over some
of them but we can see just from how the
game goes that the position is
significantly easier for uh
uh black to handle and white so white
played H4 with the idea of continuing
with H5 and H6 this is actually a very
fairly typical plan but with Knight on
f8 this is very unlikely to be
successful
and indeed after A6 just completely
securing this queen Side Pawn chain
forever H5 H6 black already has a very
pleasant position here
and indeed white decides to continue by
breaking the position open with D5 white
does have a pretty powerful Bishop here
and there's very unlikely to be a
Checkmate on the king side or anything
so this is the next most natural plan
but after Bishop C5 and takes
um
it's very difficult to suggest a good
move for White and The Game white
actually played G3 and simply allowed E5
with a closing of the position and
Knight C8 threading three route the
knights D6 black already has a pretty
sizable Advantage here in my opinion so
I think this is already a pretty good
example of the sorted potential of
Black's position I mean in this game
black was the underdog by about 150
points but managed to reach a very safe
and simply much better position just by
playing regular moves with an extra Pawn
after 93 96 Bishop G2 yeah it's very
difficult to suggest any sort of real
plans for for white
um the specific moves here are actually
not terribly important I guess just to
illustrate the uh sort of difficulties
we're seeing for white uh strong I am
here played 97 and returned to F5 which
is not uh very appetizing
for Knight C5
uh Queen G4
uh so in this case now Knight takes up
five as possible and Rook to D6 prevents
any sort of counter play with F6
um and in we're about to see in the game
a position where black is simply up a
couple of Pawns and wins fairly smoothly
yeah the specific moves I don't really
want to go into too much detail since
they're not terrifically important at
this point
but yeah essentially uh black ended up
winning this game pretty nicely from
that pawn up end game so a very good
effort so now we have to look at a
couple of cases where white plays a
little bit more critically so we just
saw that if white doesn't really do
anything uh particularly special and
just develops the pieces then we're very
likely to end up with our solid extra
Pawn
so white has two major ways to sort of
mess up our formation which as we
mentioned before just includes moves
like E6 and with a very rapid short
castling
so one of these ways is Knight D5 as
Donald has figured out
um and the other one involves a the move
B3 so B3 is a move that actually does
succeed in breaking up our Pawn chain
usually B3 is not super effective with
Knight on C3 since B4 followed by a
knight move would allow a protect to
pass upon on C3 but due to the unique
placement of our Queen on V6 well I can
play 95 and capture on C4 and I'm sure
this is something we would like to avoid
but indeed after B3 we are about to end
up in a very particular Pawn structure
which we've talked about pretty recently
the movie Bishop B4 is important to
force the white Bishop onto D2 and after
it takes takes Knight E7 in this Pawn
structure we notice a sort of repeat of
a previous game a viking Place Knight on
F3 or E2 it actually doesn't really
affect how black plays at all I believe
the stem Game hung theodoro that I was
mentioning does include the move Knight
of
of course uh
does include the what nine development
to F3
but it's not particularly important
because black will set up in the same
way every time
what I'm trying to illustrate is that
this Pawn structure is very similar to
the one we talked about earlier with uh
in the case of uh sorry where were we
it's very similar to uh
this Pawn structure we were talking
about earlier
um where uh
where white has a spawn Center but black
has this sort of outside pass Pawn
that's very annoying and indeed this
Apon mix is that it's very difficult for
white to win the game did Black have
time to take on D4
um
I can more or less assure you the answer
is no because if black could then I
would know and indeed Queen takes D4
Queen A4 check is uh winning the bishop
end of the game
um
yeah there's not really any reasonable
time you would be able to to do that
pretty much so sadly no
I wish it was possible but it is not
um anyway so here we were and so this
outside a pawn is going to make it very
difficult for white to win any sort of
end game the bishop takes D2 Queen takes
D2 We are following actually a slightly
uh higher rated uh stem game so the game
we're looking at right now uh is between
Grand Master Jeffrey Shang playing white
and linear Dominguez Perez playing Black
uh Dominguez has actually been playing
this Queen's gamut accepted quite a bit
recently which uh is good for me because
it makes me look better
um
and this was actually played at the U.S
Championship right here in St Louis last
year
um so obviously this is a very high
profile tournament so Dominguez believes
in this that strongly uh when he's
trying his hardest then I think it's a
good advertisement
um
and after Queen C6 Bishop D3 black ended
up playing Bishop A6
um by the way if white doesn't play
Knight A4 so fast a lot of the usual
points have been involved sort of A5 and
Knight C6 just to make that clear to
everybody in the audience
but in the game black saw an opportunity
to exchange the lights for Bishops with
Bishop A6 and indeed we actually end up
with a very smooth uh
or a fairly smooth draw in this game
black just ended up making defensive
moves and again white is very difficult
for white to actually piled up on this
weakness on A5 in particular with the
pawns like this it's very hard for to
imagine whites getting the requisite
pieces to take an A5 without dropping
one of these guys and indeed in the game
we're about to see how that that
actually does end up happening after
Knight B6 Knight takes D4 we're about to
see a huge liquidation which results in
most of the ponds dropping off and
indeed this position is fairly trivial
to draw for a player of dominguez's
caliber and they end up just repeating
moves
so we can see that the move B3 is uh
critical in that it does require
accuracy since white is directly
challenging the idea of our opening but
theoretic from a theoretical standpoint
we're able to stay very solid and the
resulting position ends up being fairly
difficult for white to actually make
progress in
so now we're going to talk about the
most important move Knight D5 so this is
actually contested pretty strongly in a
lot of high yellow games nowadays
um
most notably Lavon aronian keeps playing
this as white so Knight D5
so in this position
um it looks a little bit weird why we
have beta the Knight to D5 which is a
good square and we're about to see the
purpose of it very very soon so after
Knight D5 we were pretty much forced to
settle for the square B7 it's not a
super optimal square but the queen has a
surprising amount of options from here
and in this position the key move for
white is the move Bishop F4
and so at first it looks like as black
we have simply blundered since we don't
really have a super gray way to prevent
Knight C7 check which would pick up our
Rook on 8. for example a move like net
A6 is obviously not acceptable since
Rook takes A6 Queen takes A6 Knight C7
would actually drop our Queen on A6
pretty unfortunate
but here black has the opportunity to
strike back so it turns out that the
white King on E1 is fairly exposed due
to White developing the queen side so
quickly and after E5
it turns out that white already has some
immediate difficulties so first of all
white takes an E5 with a pawn then black
can continue development normally with
Bishop E6 blocking off this bishop and
black has a really excellent position
Here pawn chain is still present and
black is going to develop as per usual
of course the critical trial is Bishop
takes E5 maintaining the option of 9c7
check
and it turns out that 97 is a little bit
harder to obtain than you would expect
so by starting with Knight D7 black is
able to put pressure on the bishop and
maintain the opening of the a82 E4
diagonal and so why is this important so
first of all if white already has the
opportunity here to lose the game
immediately with Knight C7 King d8 and
taking the Rook so of course I don't
really expect any of your opponents to
lose in such a fashion but after Bishop
B4
Queen D2 is of course not particularly
dangerous to us and key to Queen takes
E4 Checkmate is very sad
um
tonight sevens are not possible as an
ip6 mistake here is black to protect
against the fourth well the problem is
it doesn't really protect against the uh
wait where would you play Knight B6 uh
yeah I don't think we have time for that
but uh
yeah after 97 so 97 well it's white to
move
so um
so so yeah so 97 is is not working for
white white does have a couple of
options here
um there's actually a relatively new
move
um
that's been played uh by a pretty strong
uh I believe she's wgm uh gold Rook
begum took care Genova who's playing to
move 92
with some ideas to set up a really
powerful knight in on D5
and so this is perfectly possible but at
the end of the day I believe black is
able to obtain full counter play it's
very difficult for me to believe that
white should be able to surrender the
two Bishops and obtain a real advantage
and indeed that's not seemed to be the
case there are many complicated lines
here which I'm not going into since a
lot of them are computer-based Perpetual
checks I will leave that to the uh
to the viewers to investigate on their
own but for the most part I believe
black has very good chances here the
White Queen is not super stable and
Black's plan is a fairly obvious
okay so after 97 the critical move is
Bishop F4 so this move prepares Moon
Knight C7 check
um and um
oh Rook takes Pawn Yeah in this position
Rook takes A7 is possible
um I believe it's not actually very good
um because after Queen B8 you are
actually exposing your Rook to 97 Knight
C6 and black has insane compensation for
this Pawn I know it's a little bit hard
to believe just looking at it now but if
you think about it in the terms like uh
that you're not gonna be able to hold on
to the E5 Pawn for very long it becomes
a little bit more convincing
um
yeah okay anyway so um
so yeah let's go back to the critical
move Bishop F4
um
so after Bishop F4
now black is actually not able to
prevent Knight C7 check there there is
no way to to prevent it move like Knight
B6 would simply lose the Rook on A8 and
we're probably going to lose the game
since the bishop is now able to go to D2
in the case of Bishop B4 so it looks
like we have simply blender and
in this game we're uh I shouldn't say in
this game but in this case we're going
to prove why that is in fact not the
case
so
uh black is now able to obtain really
exciting and dynamic play I know not
usually associated with the Queen's
gamut accepted but this is a big reason
why I favor this as a drawing opening
because if white wishes to avoid the
draws positions
um white is forced to go into some
really insane complications following
Knight F6 Knight C7 and so we're
sacrificing the entire Rook on A8 but
after Queen takes E4 check white is
ending up in a serious problem here so
uh Bishop E2 Queen takes F4 is not
really acceptable for white so 92 is the
key move but now the white pieces really
struggle to coordinate super well and
after Queen takes A8 we can stop for a
moment to take stock so first of all we
can see that black is down in exchange
for a pawn which is not ideal but at the
same time let's look at the rest of the
position so White's not on E2 makes that
it's a little bit difficult for white to
get the king side organized and Castle
the black king on d8 looks very strange
but vacates the E8 Square for the black
Rook to jump in and put pressure down
the e-file
and Black's play here seems very obvious
there's like Bishop B4 rookie 895 Bishop
B7 and all the black pieces can find
very natural squares whereas the same
cannot be said for white so this
position has actually been played in a
great deal of
uh competitive games
so white has three major moves here and
all of them are connected with the idea
of bringing the king to a short castling
so
um
so let's do it this way so let's cover
so the most popular move in this
position is actually Knight C3
and after Bishop B4 F3 Rook E8 and
Bishop E2 I think this is already a
point where we can more or less stop
analyzing as black as after A5 black is
pretty clearly having great compensation
after castles something like Queen C6
and Bishop B7
the white Bishop on E2 is basically not
a piece and therefore there is pretty
serious compensation available to Black
so
um so from here we can take a look at a
couple of
important theoretical games so the first
one we're going to look at is uh stems
from the game between aronian and
Dominguez in 2022
so in this game white played F3
so F3 has the idea of pretty much going
for a king F2 and looking to bring the
king to the king side this way without
having to move the Knight or Bishop out
from their current locations
and after Knight D5 so in this game
white has so in this position white of
course does not want to surrender the
bishop F4 so that leaves white with the
options of Bishop D2 and Bishop G5
so in the game abronian actually played
Bishop G5 the idea of this move is to
provoke F6 that is indeed what Dominguez
played but after Bishop D2 white has a
sort of improved version of the other
line as F6 is a very sub-optimal move in
that it prevents our D7 knight from
going to F6
so I believe Black's uh best move in
this position is the sort of paradoxical
move knight seven F6
so the idea here is that we although we
are pinning ourself white is very likely
to have to retreat the bishop at some
point in view of Bishop B4
and indeed uh this is actually I believe
the computer's Top Line involves the
line white to uh allow some sort of
bizarre Perpetual check like this I
believe
um it's a little bit abstract but that's
how chess goes sometimes
so
um
so yeah so aronians try here it proves
to be not particularly dangerous if
black is well prepared and so instead
white should probably go for Bishop D2
um and then here we're actually
following a different game uh where uh
with the international Master Andy
Woodward playing White against Ilya
nishnik with black but after Bishop D6
Knight C3 Knight takes and pawn takes
um so in the game Ninja played Knight B6
and eventually lost but the F6 square is
much stronger and black actually already
is rated something like 0.6 for by
stockfish which is very good considering
that we have the black pieces and white
hasn't really made any obvious mistakes
so basically the problem for white is
that most end games are not going to be
advantageous on account of this queen
Side Pawn structure and with Queens on
the white king safety is going to be a
serious issue
so that's pretty much it for F3 so
pretty good
um
and White's final option which I regard
as the most critical despite the being
probably the strangest looking is Queen
D2 so the idea of this move is to play
Knight C3 and avoid this bishop before
tactic so pretty much this move just
prevents Bishop before for a move it's
the main idea so already the fact that
the game is getting this abstract is a
good sign for us I would say
so after Knight D5
and now white wants to play at Knight C3
so in this case if we take an F4 it
turns out that white is able to
recapture the queen on F4 there's a
little bit of pressure here B5 is
hanging F7 is hanging and we have a
little bit of trouble with buck so I
think it's best to avoid this by just
developing with Bishop B4
and after Bishop E2 rookie eight so in
this position uh we are still preventing
white from castling as short castles
would drop a piece to Bishop C3 and
Knight F4
um
so Bishop G3 Knight F6 castles Knight E4
so black is actually making fairly
obvious moves black is pretty much just
improving the placement of the knights
and there's 94 we can see that although
the black king is on d8 is actually the
White Queen that is having trouble so
just because white has Castle does not
mean that does not mean that white is
out of the woods and so right now we're
actually following the game aronian
against Nakamura in the Berlin Grand
Prix I believe
and after Queen C2
so in the game Nakamura played Bishop R5
but um eventually white was able to
reach an advantage and won the game uh
pretty nicely
um it's actually pretty nice game
um but the reason I'm electing to skip
over it is because I believe it is more
accurate for black to take on C3 and
take with a bishop it looks incredibly
bizarre to lead the bishop in front of
the past pawns like this but the truth
is that it's very difficult for black
for white to push past it and these past
pawns actually do an excellent job of
shielding the black king from harm on
the queen side so at the end of the day
black should have a very nice position
here
okay so that pretty much does it for the
theoretical overview but pretty much
what I wanted to bring up was that even
this in the most complicated of lines uh
with three E4
um we're able to reach a position on our
own terms where we are the person that
holds the initiative and we're able to
reach an attacking position where indeed
there is there's quite a bit of theory I
I won't hear I won't uh I won't deny
that I won't tell you that you don't
have to memorize anything or something
like that but I would say that compared
to most openings where you get a
position this active the memorization is
very little and the ideas are more
important than anything else mostly
playing around the activity of the
pieces and this D5 Square Knight D5 97
F6 is a super powerful formation as we
saw
and with the bishop B4 rookie 8 and A5
even our Queen side majority can be an
asset in the end games
so um pretty much what you need to know
is uh like is you pretty much just need
to know this setup against E4 so if
white wishes to play Super aggressively
with the win you uh you are also allowed
to present white with the uh you're also
able to force white to go for a super
risky uh position as well so that's very
nice I feel like it's very nice to just
tell my opponent if you want to win you
have to be ready to lose so
that's the big idea here and the other
setups that we talked about with Bishop
E2 or with B3 here just proved to not be
particularly threatening and don't
really interrupt our plan of reaching a
simplified position and uh we talked
about the E3 setups before and again the
major setups there would be the iqp with
A4 or this B5 and C4 constellation and
in both cases we saw that uh there
weren't really any particular palms for
black
so yeah I think the qga is really solid
and more importantly for pretty much
everybody including myself it's very
easy to learn and we're able to uh and
if we're if we so happen to be in a
situation where a draw is relatively
fine I believe it is probably the in my
opinion the best opening that you can uh
play as black against one D4
the the only downside of it I will
mention before I leave on stream is that
if white Begins the game with Knight F3
or C4 you will have to play something
different
um not really so much against Knight F3
but you'll have to learn real openings
against this and you can't just set up
the same way so it's against one C4 you
obviously should not play D5
um but apart from that I believe it's a
super bulletproof opening against 1d4
and therefore I think this is uh I
really hope that it's able to be useful
to everybody in the audience
so um thank you so much for tuning in
and I will see you next time thank you